the One Piece manga just revealed that
princess Vivi might rejoin will Luffy
and the straw hats very soon because it
turns out that she managed to escape
from the World Government after her
father the king of alabaster was
assassinated during the meeting of the
world's most powerful Kingdom and she is
now inside the flying ship of big news
Morgans the mysterious man who controls
the media of the one piece World which
is flying directly over Egghead Island
and this now leaves us with a very
important question who will actually
join the straw hats at the end of this
Arc because next to Dr vegapunk they're
now suddenly three possible female
candidates for the next Straw Hat member
jewelry Bonnie Stussy and now Vivi so
while Oda has disappointed his fans
quite a few times now by teasing Rebecca
carrot or Yamato joining the crew before
then ultimately nothing happening there
is a whole lot of evidence that this
time things will be different so let's
look at each of our three candidates and
why they might be the 10th member Luffy
has once it for his pirate crew starting
with Stussy now at first glance Dusty
seems to be the most unlikely choice for
becoming a straw hat up until just a few
chapters ago we thought that she was an
enemy agent who wanted to capture or
even kill Luffy for the world government
however then Oda stunned his entire fan
base by revealing that Stussy was in
reality a double agent who had been
spying on the government for Dr vegapunk
all along she then betrayed Lucy and
Kaku much like they betrayed their
shipwright comrades on water 7 and she
then started helping vegapunk and the
straw hats to escape the island and
really the biggest argument for why
Stussy would not join Luffy is of course
the fact that she barely has had any
interactions with the straw hat crew so
far she has pretty much no relationship
to Luffy at all and we don't know if she
had a dream that would align with Luffy
becoming pirate king however despite all
that you might be surprised how good of
a straw hat candidate Stussy actually is
as you probably knows does he is
actually the first successfully cloned
human being in one piece history it was
created by Dr Vega Punk and his team of
scientists as a replica of Miss
Buckingham Stussy Not only was she a
member of his crew of mad scientists but
she's also the mother of Weevil and a
former member of The Rock's pirate crew
from the creators of Genji impact
hoilers comes their first ever game
title honkai star rail in case you don't
know honkai star real is the
long-awaited free-to-play 3D space
fantasy RPG for both mobile and PC
getting a glimpse at the gameplay and
worlds I can already say two things for
sure this game has an absolutely
breathtaking anime art style with a
ridiculously detailed world that feels
actually alive if you're as addicted to
anime games like Yin Shin as I am this
game promises a Next Level immersive
playing experience with fantastic story
lines awesome cutscene animation and
some truly beautiful music all available
with voice overs in four different
languages and honkai star rail is now
finally in the pre-registration phase so
make sure to use the link in the
description below to sign up right now
to get access to a ton of fantastic
pre-registration rewards and with that
back to the video now on the other hand
we don't know much yet about the past of
clones dusty but it is clear that she
must have had a very tragic one Dr
vegapunk actually tells us that as a
clone he always saw her as a human While
most other people didn't in other words
does he must have lived a life where
people around her didn't even see her as
a real person but as a clone a monster
similar to Chopper but not only that she
was then ordered by vegapunk to spend
her entire life as a double agent she
had to go through the terrible training
of the government secret agent program
kill countless people at their orders
and take on even more fake identities as
a member of zp0 in other words does he
must be a person with the worst identity
crisis in all of One Piece not only does
she not know if she's a real person but
she didn't have any real relationships
for her entire life and even the one
person that she's loyal to vegapunk had
no problem using her as a tool for her
entire life so while clone Stussy looks
very cool and composed on the surface it
wouldn't be at all surprising if we saw
a really dark and vulnerable side of her
as well and this would of course check
one of the most important boxes any new
Straw Hat needs a tragic pass and since
vegapunk is clearly not the person who
will give Stussy the sense of belonging
that she probably needs Oda could be
setting up a moment where Luffy can save
Stussy from her Darkness after all
you'll probably remember that every last
straw hat has been saved by Luffy in
some way or form which is often both
physically and mentally Luffy saved Nami
from being a servant to arlong and from
her loneliness and pain for lying to her
Village Rook from the Florian triangle
and from being lonely after losing his
entire crew or Robin from being captured
by the world government and from being
lonely after a life of being hunted and
betrayed everywhere she went in fact
stussy's story might be quite similar to
Robin both of them work for
organizations that they didn't like both
have made an enemy of the world
government and you could argue that
Stussy right now is quite similar to
Robin joining the crew after Alabaster
because if you remember back then no one
saw it coming and we didn't know much
about her until we got to water 7 well
we also have the parallel to Luchi and
zp0 and really Stussy has no other place
to go right now but to sail with the
straw hats and so Stussy could join the
crew in a casual looking way right now
until she gets her real Arc later on in
the story a role in the crew would of
course be that of a spy and I also think
that in terms of power she would make a
great addition to the crew she is a
former rocks member after all and
similar to Robin the straw hats could
become the first real family that she
ever had with Luffy saving her from her
own Darkness acknowledging her as her
own unique person which now already
brings me to our candidate number two
Vivi now for VV many fans have long
speculated that she would reunite with
the crew and become a full-blown straw
hat at some point in fact some people
will even tell you that she's been a
full-fledged member of Luffy's crew all
this time similar to how jinbei only
joined up with the rest of the crew
during one and so there are really only
two arguments why Vivi wouldn't join the
crew right now first you could make a
fairly strong argument that vivi's Arc
is basically over her dream was to free
her country Alabaster from the rule of
crocodile which Luffy helped her achieve
and second unless she had a secret Kobe
Level Training Arc over the time skip
there is simply no way that Vivi would
be able to even come close to the power
level of the crew right now so her
joining the straw hats would purely be
based on her experience as a ruler and a
diplomat and on her previous
relationships with all of the straw hats
but all of that being said though I have
always believed that there is a really
big chance that Vivi will in fact become
the 10th crew member if you remember
Vivi was basically guaranteed to join
the crew until the final twist at the
end of alabaster where she then chose
her country over her personal dream to
sail with Luffy with the murder of her
father however things have changed
dramatically we do know that emu the
secret ruler of the world seems to be
targeting the royal family of alabaster
so it's very likely that VV only
survived the meeting of the Kings
because she was able to escape with
Morgans and so while she couldn't join
the crew before because of her duty to
her country she now has nowhere to go
and not only is she really close to
Luffy right now but Luffy's also her
best chance to save her country from the
government's anger once again in other
words her dream is again perfectly
aligned with Luffy we already know that
she Vibes extremely well with the entire
crew she has been to Maurizio before and
she would represent Alabaster joining
sides with joyboy once again just how it
happened during the void Century but
despite the really strong cases we have
for both Vivi and Stussy joining the
crew right now the by far most likely
candidate for the next straw hat is in
fact our candidate number three Bonnie
now as my dear friend Mr mortgage
explained in one of his recent videos
there might not have been a better
strawhead candidate than Bonnie in one
piece since Luffy invited Jim Bay all
the way back on fisherman islands and
even if we say that she doesn't join the
crew officially right now it seems
pretty much guaranteed at this point
that she will at least travel with the
straw hats for the next coming arcs and
really there's only one good reason why
she wouldn't be able to join the crew
right now and that's the fact that
Bonnie has her own pirate ship and her
own crew because she's a member of the
worst generation just like Luffy however
even that argument doesn't seem to quite
hold up anymore because you might
remember that every time we've seen
Bonnie since the time skip there has
been no trace of either her crew or her
ship in fact it seems very likely that
they might have been taken out one time
Bonnie gets captured by Blackbeard after
the war at marineford so he might have
defeated her crew there it might have
been a kainu or it might have happened
right before she was fished out of the
water Water by the straw hats before
reaching Egghead islands that would also
explain why she was drifting in the icy
ocean overall Bonnie has been built up
to be one of the most important
characters in the entire story for the
end game but only is she inspired by
Anne Bonnie literally the most famous
real female pirate in history but as
much has rightfully noticed bani has
been the only character with a real
strong emotional storyline for the
entire Egghead Island story arc the
straw hats are basically just passing
through on a sightseeing tour and
vegapunk only got a quick introduction
so far as a character that needs a lift
off of his Island so Bonnie is really
the only character that we actually see
suffer here while we still don't know a
lot about her past it's clear from the
little pieces that we've seen so far
that Bonnie easily ticks the mark for a
tragic backstory she has also had really
bad encounters with both of Luffy's ARG
Nemesis Blackbeard and Akainu and she is
even connected to Luffy's father Dragon
through her own father Kuma and Kuma and
in extension Bonnie has been one of the
most tragic and most intensely developed
characters throughout the entire story
we do know from the reverie Arc that
Bonnie's dream is to take down the world
government and the celestial dragons for
what they did to her and her father and
this dream of course perfectly aligns
with Luffy's Journey as well it is easy
to see that Bonnie right now is in a
really dark place and that Luffy is
probably going to be the one to save her
just like he did with the other straw
hats he has already saved Bonnie
physically from drowning but I think
that Luffy will also be the one to save
Bonnie from the darkness and pain in her
heart very similar to what he did with
nami and Robin and beside all that I
think Bonnie also would make a fantastic
addition to the crew as we've seen over
the course of the story she is basically
a female version of Luffy cheerful
strong-willed a strong sense of justice
and of course a major Glutton on top of
that she also formed a real bond with
both Chopper and jimbe extremely quickly
and she also kept Zorro from cutting
down a Celestial Dragon all the way back
on sabaori though she was clearly
impressed by both Luffy and Zorro being
willing to attack the world Nobles and
so similarly to Robin Bonnie belongs
with the straw hats because they are the
only ones willing to declare war on the
government that has chased them their
entire life as the daughter of an actual
King Not only would Bali finally fill
the empty princess slot in the straw hat
crew but as a member of the worst
generation she would also be strong
enough to fight with the rest of the
crew easily that plus her incredibly
powerful and unique devil fruit
abilities but overall it's really hard
to say who of these three women will end
up joining Luffy it could be that once
again Oda denies as a new member as he's
done so many times before or it could
also be that all three join at the same
time I mean who knows Bonnie and Stussy
would make perfect additions to the crew
and VV as a quasi Straw Hat already is
about to reunite with the crew thanks to
big news Morgans and speaking of that
don't you find it odd how interested
Morgan seems to have always been in
Luffy that was even the case all the way
back during whole cake Island and
Morgan's also knows Stussy now a fact
that you might not know is that Morgans
isn't a mink or some sort of animal that
can talk instead he's a man that has
eaten the albatross devil fruit and is
constantly in his hybrid form to
disguise his true identity so who could
this man really be well what if I told
you that big news Morgans might actually
be a former member of the Raja Pirates
and maybe even nami's long-lost father
if you want to find out more about that
you can watch the entire Theory right
here Shanks for watching